[Applause]
this had been brewing for days it was
almost inevitable the migrants charging
through police lines battering past the
riot shields trying to reach the border
fence with the United States men women
and children from the asylum seeking
Caravan suddenly upping the stakes
clashing with police overwhelmed by the
charge and their positions authorities
try to steer them away from the border
but failed I always say this is two
somewhat chaotic now they've actually
got through the police lines and they're
running now towards the border some are
being held but quite a few hundred have
got through they streamed across a huge
sewage canal heading to the building on
the far side that is the way into the
United States
[Music]
they jostle over a walk many believing
they were about to reach America the
stinking waterway beneath them was not
going to stop them they carried their
possessions any way they could charging
on for the first time within a few feet
of their goal after thousands of miles
on the road
the police scrambling reinforcements to
stop the advance and potentially an even
more chaotic encounter with the American
military blocks from getting into the
terminal proper they pushed through a
fence to the cross-border train lines
scrambling a bus sandy rocky embankment
pulling each other up encouraging
themselves for a charge on the fence and
then they were there the crowd forced
their way through a weak point and for
son they finally reached the United
States but not for long US border
officers fired tear gas forcing them
back and here the rounds being fired
[Music]
some were hit by canisters or rubber
bullets US military helicopters hovered
above the crowd and armed United States
officers patrol defense waiting for the
Mexican police to restore order they
eventually did forcing the migrants back
into Tijuana fighting broke out with
locals in the police moved in and made
arrests many will be deported
immediately this was perhaps inevitable
and nobody knows what will happen next
but the migrant caravan won't get much
sympathy and especially not in the White
House
durante skynews 51